JAPAN’S PEAK:
On December 29, 1989, Japan’s stock market
index reached a value of 38,957 points.
From there, the index saw a decent sell off
of about 30% over the next couple of months.
Not much was thought of this at the time given
that there was a global market sell off.
So, most assumed that this was just a routine
bear market.
But, the bear market quickly became much more
painful.
Within 9 months after the peak, the index
would crash all the way down to 19,760 points
which correlates to about a 50% sell off.
By this point, it was clear that this was
no longer just a routine bear market.
This was now a monumental crash similar to
the dotcom crash or the 2008 financial recession
that people would remember for decades.
Fortunately from there, it seemed like the
bottom was in.
The index would bounce a solid 37% and no
new lows would be formed for well over a year.
But, if you invested during this time period,
you would soon be regretting it because the
index would make yet another leg down by the
end of 1992, falling a total of 63%.
If I was a Japanese citizen during this time
period, I would’ve almost definitely been
all in.
And every month, I’d probably be chucking
my entire paycheck at the index, thinking
that it was just a matter of time until this
thing recovered.
And that’s what it seemed like for a very
long time.
For the next 8 years, the index would bounce
between 13,000 and 23,000 points and seemingly
built a massive base.
Surely, this was the base that was required
to support the next bull market.
But, the exact opposite would take place once
again.
At the turn of the century, the dotcom bubble
would burst which push the index all the way
down to 7500 points.
This was no longer just a stock market crash,
this was a full on stock market depression
comparable to that of the great depression.
But, even this was not the bottom.
The real bottom wouldn’t come till November
of 2008 when the index crashed a total of
82%.
Since then, the index has recovered substantially
growing over 300%, but even today, we have
yet to surpass the all time high that was
set nearly 33 years ago and that’s with
inflation.
And with the global economy entering yet another
downturn, it doesn’t seem like Japan will
be making any new all time highs in the imminent
future.
This doesn’t just apply to the Japanese
stock market either.
If we switch over to the real estate market,
we’ll see that a very similar trend has
materialized.
After decades of growth, the real estate market
peaked out in 1991 before crashing 50%.
And even today, the market is down about 30%.
If we take a look at their GDP numbers, we’ll
see a slightly better picture.
Instead of going straight down and not recovering,
their GDP has more or less gone sideways for
30 years.
But, for a country like Japan that was once
universally known for innovation and progress,
this too is disappointing.
So, what in the world happened to Japan and
is this what’s eventually in store for America?
UNPRECEDENTED GROWTH:
Even though the Japanese stock market didn’t
peak out till the end of the 80s, the seeds
for devastation had been planted decades earlier.
It all started right after WW2.
The war had destroyed Japan in every sense,
physically, economically, mentally, spiritually,
you name it.
The Japanese empire had diverted almost everything
they had to the war effort for several years,
and all they had to show for it was pure devastation.
And to put salt on the wound, there were nearly
a million American soldiers occupying their
largest cities.
But, while morale was at all time lows, something
was changing behind the scenes.
The reason America was occupying Japan was
to make sure that Japan didn’t try to pull
a quick on and start another conflict.
In other words, America was basically trying
to babysit Japan, but the dynamics of this
relationship rapidly evolved into being a
partnership.
You see, it didn’t take long for America
to realize that Japan wasn’t the biggest
threat.
The biggest threat was actually the soviet
union, and it was in America’s best interest
to have a partner in the east.
The only two viable candidates for this role
were of course Japan and China.
And given that China was barreling towards
a communist revolution, America had to choose
Japan.
So, over the next several years, they worked
with Japan to establish a western capitalist
economy.
General Douglas MacArthur worked with Japanese
leaders to implement a new constitution that
prioritized a limited government, free and
fair elections, private property, and individual
liberties.
They also eased off on the ridiculous income
tax that went up to 86%.
These changes set up Japan for success, and
after the Americans left in the early 1950s,
Japan was off to the races.
Between 1950 and 1973, Japan would grow at
twice the rate of Western Europe and 2.5 times
the rate of America during the 1960s.
This resulted in their stock market exploding
a mind boggling 6100%.
While this is no doubt extraordinary, one
caveat that we should note is that Japan was
growing from nearly zero.
So, they had a lot more headroom to grow than
traditional western countries, and such growth
was obviously not sustainable indefinitely.
But, Japan wanted to make it indefinite and
this is what would eventually seal their fate.
THE PLAZA ACCORD:
As you might’ve guessed, the main way in
which Japan tried to keep the growth going
was through money printing.
But, we can’t blame them too much because
growth wasn’t the only reason that Japan
was printing money.
Japan’s choice to print money was actually
overseen and backed by all of the most prominent
western countries through an agreement called
the Plaza Accord.
The Plaza Accord was an agreement between
the G-5 nations, and was actually designed
to help Japan and Germany.
You see, while the Japanese and German economies
had grown exponentially since WW2, there was
still a massive trade imbalance between these
countries and the United States.
The main reason for this was the rapid appreciation
of the US dollar in the 1980s.
After a decade of high inflation in the 1970s,
the US finally put their foot down and jacked
up rates all the way to 20%.
While this move was effective in cooling down
inflation and helping the dollar appreciate
47.9%, this move also had some unintended
consequences like the trade imbalance.
A strong dollar meant that it was extremely
expensive for foreign countries like Japan
and Germany to buy US goods.
And for companies with a large international
presence, this was terrible news, so they
decided to lobby congress to weaken the dollar
which eventually resulted in the Plaza Accord.
Instead of focusing on growth, the US agreed
to focus on addressing their budget deficit.
Meanwhile, Germany and Japan agreed to cut
taxes, lower interest rates, and of course
print money to hopefully stimulate their economies.
This plan actually worked out surprisingly
well as the US dollar fell as much as 25.8%
within the next two years.
This nearly eliminated the trade deficit between
the US and Germany, but the deficit between
Japan and the US was still non-negligible.
Nonetheless, the US didn’t want to overdo
the weakening of the dollar, so they would
implement another accord called the Louvre
Accord.
This accord was meant to essentially reverse
all of the policies set forth by the Plaza
Accord and stabilize exchange rates.
But even though the Louvre accord was signed
rather proactively, it seems that Japan had
already overdone the economic loosening as
asset prices had way too far.
MONSTROUS VALUATIONS:
A lot of people like to claim that the overvalution
of the US stock market in 2020 and 2021 was
the worst that we’ve seen.
But, in reality, that was nothing in comparison
to the Japanese stock market in the late 1980s.
Take the price to earnings ratio for example.
The median for the S&P 500 over the past 90
years is 14.90.
In 2020 and 2021, this ratio reached levels
of 35 to 40, so there’s no doubt the US
stock market was overvalued, and it’s just
now starting to return to normal levels.
But, do you what levels the Japanese stock
market reached?
Well, it reached PE ratios of 60.
For perspective, the US only reached PE ratios
of 44 even during the Dotcom bubble.
The US did reach PE ratios as high 123 during
the financial crisis, but that wasn’t due
to asset valuations getting super high.
It was actually due to corporate earnings
falling off a cliff which screwed up the ratio.
This wasn’t what was happening in Japan.
They straight up just had a PE ratio of 60.
This meant that their stock market would have
to crash 75% just to return to normal levels.
A very similar trend was beginning appear
within the real estate market as well.
By 1985, Tokyo’s commercial districts had
already reached full capacity.
This meant that if you wanted a piece of the
pie, you had to buy it from someone else.
And given that the economy was booming, there
wasn’t very many people who were willing
to sell.
This quickly resulted in buyers becoming desperate.
Combine this with record low interest rates,
and it didn’t take long for real estate
to turn into one massive bidding war.
In 1984, one square meter of land in Tokyo’s
commercial district cost $5,600.
By 1985, this rose to $7,958 per square meter.
As you can see, prices were already skyrocketing,
and when you threw the Plaza accord into the
mix, things went parabolic.
By 1986, a single square meter of commercial
land cost $25,000.
By 1987, this rose to $45,000.
And by 1989, we were talking about an eye
watering $218,000 per square meter.
For my fellow metrically disabled peers, that
translates to $20,000 per square feet.
Certain parts of Tokyo had appreciated 40X
in a matter of 5 years.
And at this point, it was just a matter of
time until valuations collapsed.
To make things worse, Japan was also starting
to undergo a demographics crisis.
As countries develop, birth rates tend to
go down, and eventually, they become so low
that the country is no longer self sustaining.
This has actually happened to the US as well,
but thanks to America’s relatively generous
immigration policies, the country has been
able to continue growing.
Japan’s immigration policies, however, have
never been as leniant as America’s, and
many experts even go as far as claiming that
Japan’s immigration policies are self destructive.
And when you combine declining demographics
with ludicrous asset valuations, Japan is
what you get.
THE LOST DECADES:
This monumental decline in Japan was initially
dubbed the lost decade, but it has since been
revised to be named the lost decades.
And honestly, there’s no sugar coating it.
Japan’s economy has stagnated for 3 decades,
and with the current economic decline, it
seems highly likely that that will turn into
4 decades.
Japan’s financial situation doesn’t make
things any better.
Japan is the most indebted country in the
world relative to their GDP coming in a painful
237%.
Even the US with our ridiculous $31 trillion
is only at 125% or about half of that of Japan.
But, honestly none of that is even Japan’s
biggest concern.
By far Japan’s biggest concern is their
waning demographics. 28.7% of Japan’s population
is over the age of 65 and only 12.3% are under
the age of 15, so in terms of young ambitious
souls, they don’t have very many.
We should also mention that their migrant
population has also been on the decline.
And without a positive change in their demographic
profile or some sort of innovative miracle,
I just don’t see how Japan can enter another
highly prosperous period anytime soon.
As for how this applies to the US, given that
our markets are almost back to normal levels,
and given that our immigration numbers are
still relatively strong, I don’t think we’re
headed into some sort of 30 to 40 year long
bear market, but that’s just what I think.
When do you think this current economic decline
will come to a close?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you hope that your country
doesn’t end up like Japan.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.